[Applause]
Democrat Andy Beshear says he's won
Kentucky's race for governor
it was a tight election especially for a
conservative leaning state it's a
message that says our elections don't
have to be about right versus left they
are still about right versus wrong it's
seen as a setback for president Donald
Trump who easily won Kentucky in 2016
Kentucky
personally campaigned for Republican
governor Matt Bevin was a recent fights
with labor unions and teachers made him
among the least popular governors in the
country here's a stir if you win they're
gonna make it like ho-hum and if you
lose they gonna say Trump suffered the
greatest defeat in the history of the
world this was the greatest you can't
let that happen to me in the one swing
state of Virginia Democrats won the
majority in both the House and the
Senate a first in more than two decades
Virginia is officially blue
congratulations the ships could give the
party control to pass controversial laws
on gun control that were previously
blocked by Republicans in the
conservative state of Mississippi
Republicans won big Tate Reeves took the
governor's seat against the state's
Attorney General Jim hood the victory
seen as a sign of stability for Trump a
year before the presidential race these
elections are a glimpse into what
President Trump could expect in his 2020
reelection bit including whether the
democrat-led impeachment inquiry is
swaying his base kotse lupus of a yawn
al Jazeera